hello and welcome to this video playing
the Tasmanian Devil okay
the Vienna game I've haven't looked at
this for ages
yeah Knight f3 is the normal move and
this is possible but not particularly
great I think f5 is good that that's a
bit out there what's good think f5 is
right
hmm
huh
I don't really know if I maybe my memory
was wrong because that looks odd yeah
odd for me
hmm probably it isn't have five Kareena
three is not a good move you can get a
better position there were black against
it but I didn't do it right
yeah this is this is getting tricky
already 95 he probably goes Queenie to
and I'm in some trouble maybe it
actually is okay
Queeny to queenie 795 okay it doesn't do
it anyway
and here I think I should be okay yeah
sure it should be okay I get to Castle
very quickly and then that 97 issue is
not really a problem
no yeah I'm okay
now probably equal maybe maybe I can do
something with the pawn structure there
yeah I don't want to take so probably
just drop back
hmm interesting so I probably should
take everything look we should be seven
look PA I have not H what a night see to
at the end which seems like a problem
hmm just resigned yeah I got 92 so a bit
of a sudden resignation um yeah I'm
winning but so you said early yeah f5 is
right okay
it's what the engine at least gives
there should go d4 here yeah yeah I am
immediately attacking this and isolating
the pawn that's very important that the
pawn on e5 cannot be supported to the D
form this is the key move that I did not
have a head on the right hand did I that
I did not have on the right oh yeah
that's a lot better
this isn't so good so great sturdy form
but was there something entirely wrong
with with my play here that that's what
I'm interested in
Queeny to go I would have played Queen
to d7
um Bishop d6 is actually fine
interesting because I can Castle yeah
okay this is not something you easily
see
yeah because here here I got a huge
attack group he made and so on I didn't
know I would have played Queen to e7
Knight takes Queen d6 and I thought I
should be okay he's got c4 Wow didn't
really didn't really register
g6 seems to be the only playable move
now and they don't trust that yeah that
would have been problematic because that
that that is the position that we would
have gotten and here
it's probably just okay we should be too
and yet defile this is not good yeah
okay it's until you trouble and the
engine gives Knight g4 that's
interesting
oh yeah this is actually very nice route
hmm
it seems to be better
and he d5 yeah I thought that that was
would be okay it is okay for me it just
like and I don't have an advantage
according to the comp which I probably
can get the mochi for him here in the
game he should check on c6 which is of
course not something he would like to do
which it's better than the game here
here I'm really almost winning yeah and
I'll get the pawn and the whole position
is really bad you know
in early resignation but it is actually
advantage for me okay thanks a lot for
watching